[Music]
I was 6 years old when the plane crashed
in 1970 I was sitting at home with my
brothers watching television with my Mom
and Dad we heard the sirens blaring my
mother's nephews were actually First
Responders so were always very attentive
when we heard a siren so the phone calls
began to be made the were CB scanners
which were basically radio scanners to
see where the police or the fir trucks
were being dispatched all the neighbors
were talking about there had been a
plane crash and so I ran to the back
window and I looked out and I could see
the haze in the sky glowing red and you
could see that that fire basically was
happening and at that moment in time I
started to see the beginning of A Life
Lesson which is that we're all born
angels with One Wing and the way we
flies behold n to one another so I'll
never forget how that Community came
together and helped each other Rise From
the
Ashes Brad Smith is the former CEO of in
which is the company behind QuickBooks
and Turbo Tax and since January of 2022
he's been the president of Zelma moer
which is Marshall University in West
Virginia Smith grew up in a small town
of about 3,000 people called Kenova West
Virginia which is right next to Marshall
and back in 19 70 there was a plane
crash near campus that killed 75 people
including the school's whole football
team viewers probably know these events
for later depicted in the Matthew mccon
movie We Are Marshall he and his
brothers were the first in their family
to go to college and he initially went
to West Point but he ultimately decided
to go back home to Marshall after a
semester and he still wears the Marshall
class ring that his dad gave him right
before he had a heart attack a few days
later after receiving his master's
degree in management from aquinus
College of Michigan Brad took a sales
job at PepsiCo initially despite an
early boss's insistence that he attend
corporate Communications courses to rid
himself of his West Virginia Twain Smith
quickly climbed the corporate ladder at
7 Up and Direct Mail marketer advo with
the inherent flaw of his accent proudly
intact my dad taught me serve at
leadership My dad became the mayor of
that hometown of 3000 in Kenova and he
became known as something that other
Mayors hadn't done he rode the
sanitation trucks every week he would
ride with the drivers as they picked up
the trash in the city and I asked him
one day I said dad why do you ride the
sanitation trucks why are you not in the
office he said Son first of all this is
the best way to get to know your tame
you ride eight hours in a truck with
someone you learn about their family you
learn about the things that keep them
awake at not and you learn about how you
can help them and the second is there's
no better way to know your city than to
go down the back of the alley not in the
front where everyone has it all spruced
up so I know where the real problems are
that we can help solve so I got the
Pepsi I became known as the young
district sales manager that rode the
routes with the drivers and when they
called in sick I delivered the soft
drinks in the snow and at the end of the
day they always remembered that I was
willing to work with them and so when we
had sales contests we won every time not
because of me but because the drivers
knew that I was in it with them and it
ended up helping my career cuz I simply
served them and in return they did great
work after rising to the role of senior
vice president of marketing and business
development over seven years at ADP
Smith joined into it in 2003 as vice
president and general manager of its
accountant Central and developer Network
just 5 years later he was running the
entire company Smith inherited a
25-year-old business with really
tremendous brand Equity whose Turbo Tax
and QuickBooks software products were
beloved by individuals and small
businesses alike but few could have
foreseen its radical transformation over
the next decade its market
capitalization soared almost sfold to 51
billion and revenues nearly doubled to
$6 billion by
2018 so when I joined into it I had the
opportunity to join the accountants
business in Dallas Texas in Plano Texas
the company was known as a leadership
development Factory and started out in
the accountant business then I was asked
to go to Turbo Tax and Lead that
business in San Diego and then I was
asked to move up to QuickBooks the small
business Division and Lead that business
so over 5 year period I'd had a chance
to see all the corners of the company at
that time when I was then asked to step
in as CEO and they announced it in
August of 2007 that I would take the
role in January 2008 I knew that I had
the privilege to serve an iconic company
that had a strong Foundation but
candidly in 2008 there were a few things
happening the first was we had started
to see social platforms like Facebook
move off of the education campuses and
move into the do world so you had this
notion of social the second is Steve
Jobs had just released the iPhone so
this move to mobility and mobile became
big and then ultimately because of the
cloud we were starting to see local
markets become Global so we stepped back
and said we're going to be the same
great company we are but we're going to
lean into being more of a connected
Services Company an analyst told me Brad
understood the power of the cloud early
on and not just on the application side
for their taxs and QuickBooks businesses
he also shut down all their own data
centers and moved their data to Amazon
web services and Google Cloud which
really positioned them well to take
advantage of AI now into its billionaire
founder Scott Cook told me that Smith's
impact on the company goes beyond
business results cook called Brad quote
the ultimate servant leader and told me
that Brad had changed the lives of the
company's customers and employees lives
forever when Smith left into it in
January 2022 at the height of his career
the company etched his signature phrase
work hard be kind take pride in stone on
the face of its headquarters which was
recently renamed for Smith we had
developed a balance score card where it
was employes first customers and our
community second our shareholders third
and I began to tell the stories about
why because everyone saw it clinically
but I don't think they really understood
it ideologically so we said if we were a
human body the employees are the oxygen
they're the air the body can only make
it about 3 minutes without air and it
begins to shut down and then they go to
customers and communities they are the
water you can make it about 3 days but
then the body starts to shut down then
ultimately you have the shareholders as
a public company they own the company
but they're the food you can make it two
or three weeks and the body shuts down
so you have to serve all of them but it
begins with employees first who are
there with one purpose in mind to do
amazing things for customers in their
Community if you have great employees
who are fired up and you've supported
them and you've taught them they'll do
unbelievable things for customers and
communities and as a result the
shareholders will win so we became an
employee Centric company with a purpose
and our purpose was to power prosperity
to fight for the overlooked and the
underserved to help those who struggle
to make it paycheck to paycheck which
was a story that many of us grew up with
and we could be the ones that could be
their champion and that's what really
bonded us
together Brad's sudden move from
Mountain View to the mountain state
really shocked many in the industry but
you know to those who knew him it really
made sense um because they'd heard him
reminisce about West Virginia over the
years Smith and his wife Elise a lawyer
from Ohio with a shared love for
Appalachia founded their education
entrepreneurship and environment focused
Wing Towing foundation in 2019 but their
philanthropy in the region goes back
even further just since 2015 they've
donated $35 million to Marshall to
establish a scholarship that gives
preference to first generation students
from West Virginia and Ohio and to
transform its recently renamed Brad D
Smith schools of
business so first of all when he stepped
down um we thought wow we'll finally
have an opportunity to spend a little
more family time well that's just not
the case because Brad is a Workhorse
he's wired to work he would do coaching
Executive coaching he would coach
entrepreneurs and he would do that 12
hours a day but he was unfulfilled and
then he got a call from several people
actually saying hey would you be willing
to consider becoming the president of
Marshall University you know the job's
going to open up and at first he thought
h no no no this this is not something
I'm interested in you know so he he
mentions it to me when we're in South
Carolina we're we're taking a walk on
the beach and he mentions it and uh I
immediately said oh oh no I'm not going
to West Virginia I mean I I love
California
and then we decided to go through the
whole procon thing we decided you know
what let's get this opportunity a real
shot and ultimately we just decided you
know what you're not happy doing what
you're doing Brad I've been looking for
something that makes me feel that I'm
doing what I was meant to do and here's
that opportunity let's just do it the
couple also has an outdoor Economic
Development collaborative named after
them at rival West Virginia University
thanks to a $25 million gift in 2020
that's being used to recruit and retain
talented out of-state workers and to
develop outdoor recreation resources in
the area clearly we want to focus on
Appalachia because Appalachia is both
overlooked and underserved and that is
the community that we want to focus on
because very few others do you know all
the VC firms in the country Focus most
of their money on California New York
and
Boston and the people in Appalachia are
every bit as bright and talented as
anybody in those locations we can do
everything that they can do and and
quite honestly maybe better and so we
decided that we would focus our energy
and our our money on helping people in
Appalachia have greater opportunity and
we chose these three areas because we
think they're the great equalizers
particularly education
it's by far the great equalizer um it
can raise anyone up to do whatever they
dream dream of in their
lives there is a period of reinvention
happening at higher ed right now you
have the enrollment Cliff coming fewer
High School seniors will be graduating
starting in 2025 that number is going to
go down 15% a year across the country
you have fewer High School seniors who
are now also less likely to go to
college and so the number of those that
want to go to college is decreasing by
12% you've got digital transformation
you have all these amazing things like
chat GPT or you have KH Academy or you
have corsera or YouTube so all these
alternatives to learning and so it was a
chance to step back and say how can we
as Marshall University hold on to the
186 years of things that we've done but
embrace the new ways and be the platform
for the 21st century and so when I
stepped in we facilitated a process
across the campus 38 listening sessions
1,000 people 1,200 ideas we engaged with
two outside firms and we began to
explore the best practices all around
the globe and we developed a strategy
that we're now following called Marshall
for all Marshall forever Marshall forall
Marshall forever is focused on a value
proposition that has three components a
affordability
flexibility and
achievement since 20 7 the average
college tuition's gone up 10% a year and
student loan debt has grown
45% that's become a barrier to a lot of
people who need access to a college
degree so we're tackling affordability
I'll talk about how in a minute the
second is flexibility many students
today are non-traditional students
they're working adults they may have
dropped out for a period of time they
may have a kid they may have a full-time
job they can't come to class in the
middle of a work shift so you need to
basically be able to have a flexible
work schedule and a flexible class
schedule and then the third is
achievement they want to know that
they're going to have the ability to get
a degree or to get a certificate and
then have that translate into some sort
of earnings potential so Marshall for
all Marshall forever is that we're going
to have an in demand
curriculum that teaches OnDemand classes
so you can take them online you can take
them in a classroom or you can take them
a hybrid environment and we've chosen
where we're going to be distinctive our
goal is for individual success one 100%
of our students will graduate they will
get the career of their choice and 0%
will have student loan debt so our first
promise is 100% placement zero debt the
second promise is we're going to take
our research our grants and contracts
that Advance innovative ideas from
today's $65 million to 150 million and
in doing that one increase the number of
small businesses getting started in our
state by
3x and then economic impact today
Marshall for every dollar State invest
in Marshall we give them a 14x return
our goal is to make it 30X that's $2.5
billion so we've set those True North
goals and everyone here is fired up and
to let you know it can be real we just
admitted the first 100 students this
fall on the guarantee that they will
have a job and no student loan
debt thing I was most uh struck by in
talking with Brad and doing my reporting
um was just you know how personal it is
to him and it comes across as as totally
authentic you know he talks about
believing there are as many Geniuses uh
there in West Virginia as there are as
in Silicon Valley and you know he he
gave up a lot to to go back and do what
he's doing West Virginia have always
answered the call we've mined the coal
we forged the steel we built the roads
we built the trucks we fought the wars
when our president said we want to have
a man on the moon we produced Homer
Hickam and the boys in October Sky that
built the first NASA rockets and then
when we needed that astronaut home we
produced Katherine Johnson and The
Hidden figures and brought him home and
for a while people told us we didn't
belong and we believed him I don't we do
belong we've got another chapter and
we're showing the world Who We
Are